bro i ain't got no problem my [ __ ] i do
the ground work [ __ ] i'm like i'm
running i don't
tell me when you say indy
are you like who are you doing the
distro kid the tune core thing like how
are you like distributing your music uh
to uh
orchard okay orchard okay okay through
the orchard so they and they distro they
do distro yes
sony right sony orchard yeah yeah
yeah i get them fifty percent
you feel me
they they uh
they give me like
jpeg like [ __ ] that tooncourt couldn't
do yeah they'll give you a budget
they'll help i i i get it 100 yeah like
they like they
they gonna give you the money
right
but it ain't like no guidance like that
like [ __ ] is here we go
all right here's the money what are you
gonna do with it that's on you
you gotta make sure your team is
together you gotta make sure you know
what you one day i called and was like
yeah they asking for what's name what's
that he said oh you gotta pay them
i'm like oh so you're like bro you still
independent bro mm-hmm he like [ __ ]
major
was this your first project through
orchard
okay
so
prior to that you were just doing the
distro kit thing huh yeah no tunecore
tunecore
core district same [ __ ]
yeah and that's what my manager was like
bro yeah bro like
we gonna help you my [ __ ] like we're
gonna help you uh
[ __ ]
that's why those peop people was because
the big labels was hitting me
like the label labels of course it's
distro
so
i mean free joe exotic is such a big
record independently that [ __ ] is crazy
that
like that was such a moment you know
what i'm saying like
it's the kind of record that could
change anyone's life yeah and that's
when my mans was just like bro
you wanted to be independent they could
put your big boy drawers on me mm-hmm
do it do your [ __ ] so
i just turned it up like i was just back
at back back
when i was um
didn't have no record just making
relationships just trying to do whatever
so i'm like [ __ ] it
let's get out here so everything you see
from this relationship with these
artists to
me doing this [ __ ]
that's that's that's me running up on
[ __ ] tapping the [ __ ] dm
getting him hey tell him i got this [ __ ]
tell him i'm trying to say
like me like i'm i'm running on the
ground